if you've been thinking about buying a
new iphone stop right there in your
tracks do not do it because we're gonna
be getting the new iphone 14 lineup in
less than one month yes it was just
confirmed by mark german the most
reliable apple leaker that apple
september event is happening on
september 7th which is a wednesday and
yes they always release their new
iphones on that day and even better he
says that we're actually gonna have the
iphone 14 models in our hands on
september 16th yes less than a month
from today and i recommend waiting
because those new iphone 14s especially
the 14 pro models are going to be
absolutely insane there's going to be
some
crazy revolutions like in the camera
department as well as others with some
new features that we've never had on the
iphone that android has had for many
years and not only that but this year
there are going to be even more features
that are going to be exclusive to the
iphone 14 pro and there's one that i
really want to focus on it's something
that's going to fix an issue that has
been plaguing the iphones for years
especially since the iphone 12 and even
this 13
model so before i get into explaining
that i've got to go through some of the
contacts first of all the iphone 14 pro
is gonna get the a16 chip compared to
the standard iphone 14 models retaining
the a15 so yes it's gonna have even more
performance than it already has now we
did get a report this morning saying
that tsmc is starting their three
nanometer chip production for the m2 pro
and then the future a17 for the iphone
15 next year but what that means is that
the current iphone 14 pro that we're
about to get in less than a month is
going to be sticking to the a16 which
unfortunately according to shrimp apple
pro a leaker on twitter he says that the
a16 bionic is gonna continue to use the
same five nanometer from tsmc's n5p yes
that's exactly what we already have on
the a15 bionic and it is going to be
offering slightly better cpu performance
faster ram and a better gpu but there is
a very big problem with this the iphone
13 pro with the a15 chip especially with
the 5 core gpu model it suffers from
thermal throttling that is lowering the
performance as you can see right here in
geekbench performance charts you have
the apple a15 bionic right here in the
iphone 13 and the iphone 13 mini and
they score around 11
200 points which is crazy crazy fast
that's in terms of metal graphics but
take a look at this the apple a14 bionic
yes that's the last generation chip is
actually faster and that's with the same
four core gpu 12
425 yes the previous gen a14 faster than
the new a15 in the iphone 13 and the
reason for that is thermal throttling
due to the lack of a decent cooling
solution yes these iphones use passive
cooling just like the ipad except the
ipad is larger so it's able to dissipate
the heat across the larger tablet
compared to the smaller iphone which
heats up faster and because of that
apple literally caps the performance of
that chip down lower quite a bit lower
than the a14 now if you look at the a15
bionic chip in the iphone 13 pro those
do score higher because they have a five
core gpu however it's not much faster
than the four core version and then if
you split that up into performance per
core the a14 in the ipad air is getting
more performance per core and that's of
course because the iphone just can't
handle the heat the cooling solution
sucks well thankfully apple is working
on a solution to this problem and it's
why i think these new iphone 14 pro
models are gonna be incredibly good in
terms of everyday reliability and
performance as well yes apple has been
aggressively testing vapor chamber
cooling solutions for the 2022 iphones
yes that's finally this year and that is
going to allow them to really unlock the
performance of the a16 ship now if you
don't know how that works there are some
other phones that actually already have
vapor chamber cooling and as you can see
right here this is a copper vapor
chamber cooler and what happens is at
the source of the heat whereas where the
chip is it heats up and hot air moves
around sort of in this loop where it
goes to a different location and it
comes back around a little bit colder
than it was before and it just cycles
around like this allowing the chip to
stay cooler sort of like a radiator in
an engine so if this year apple
engineers a well-designed vapor chamber
cooler for the iphone 14 pro and pro max
models that literally by itself could
lead to a huge performance boost
compared to what we have right now with
the iphone 13 models because we have
just so much performance that is locked
behind the overheating so literally with
the same a15 chip that we already have
we could get a big performance boost and
because of that it kind of makes sense
for why apple is sticking to the n5p
five nanometer process node on the a16
chip because if they improve the cooling
that's gonna do a lot of the performance
work for them by unlocking the extra
performance which means they won't have
to do that much tweaking to the a16 ship
at all they just have to tweak it a
little bit and it'll look like it's a
new awesome super fast chip but really
it was the cooling that did most of the
work so apple has a huge advantage and
opportunity this year by adding a vapor
chamber cooler now on top of that we are
going to be getting a new 5g chip that's
going to be cooler it's going to be the
snapdragon 865 which is using the six
nanometer process which is more
efficient than the x60 that they're
using right now and that's gonna lead to
less heat and of course better battery
life as well so we'll have less display
dimming issues because the display
dimming issue was huge with the iphone
12 it got better with the iphone 13 but
it's still around and it's still very
annoying so that vapor chamber cooling
along with the new 5g chip that could
mean that we'll finally get rid of the
display dimming issues on the iphone 14
pro and pro max now not only that but we
are expecting even more awesome
exclusive features with the 14 pro and
pro max model first of all we're getting
taller displays and as you can see we're
finally getting rid of the notch you
have the pro max right here in the pro
they have this new pill shaped and
single hole punch cutouts that look a
lot better than the old notched version
not only that but we get a really slim
and sleek speaker grille and the bezels
themselves look thinner not only that
but the pro models are getting the new
48 megapixel camera system which i think
is going to record 8k video at 60 fps
that's going to be exclusive to the 14
pro models not only that but we're also
getting the always on display feature on
the pro models because they're going to
have new display panels that can go down
to one hertz refresh rate finally giving
us a feature that's been around on
android for many many years and the
regular iphone 14 is not getting that
and even better we might even get 256
gigs of base storage with the 14 pro
alongside the rumored price increase
which might be around 100 more expensive
than it is right now for the 13 pro and
the pro max model so with that said
apple has some huge opportunities this
year to make the iphone 14 pro a lot
better with the vapor chamber cooler and
all of those other features and because
of that i strongly believe that you
should not be buying any iphone model
right now you should be waiting until
apple's september 7th event because i
think you'll be blown away by the new
features we're getting in the iphone 14
lineup now if you totally disagree with
my thoughts let me know down in the
comment section below but if you like
this video click the circle button
subscribe and check out one of those two
right over there thanks for watching and
we'll see you in the next video
[Music]